this video is sponsored by figurama
collectors
[Music]
[Applause]
as we move towards the end of yet
another jam-packed season we all know
what's coming you guys like fights and
it's in my best interest to give you
what you want so here we go
top fight of the winter anime season as
expected for such a jam-packed season
this winter 2021 has a whole gallery of
amazing fights that would satisfy
all your cravings and more before we get
going i'd like you guys to subscribe to
this channel
it does help me a lot and i'll be so
happy to reach the next major milestone
for the channel and this
community so let's do it together
everyone i don't want to keep you
waiting any longer so let's get going
with our top fights this winter 2021
we start with a shortie team dead end
versus red hood cobra
one thing that amazes me frankly
speaking is just how much effort and
love's getting poured into mushoku
tensei
look a freaking studio is created just
for the show and it's more or less
confirmed to be a long runner with the
team more or less poised to adapt the
series all the way to the end
just a testament of their passion can be
seen in this short battle between team
dead end and the red hood cobra it's a
short battle
lasting a little less than a minute long
but you can clearly see how well crafted
it was in anime form from the team's
attacks
to the camera cuts and animations with
each twist and turn the battle took
i won't place this battle as anywhere
near the top three or anything but if
you want the embodiment of the phrase
short but sweet
among the plethora of winter fights this
one would be it
one piece continues its run of
excellence all through the new year
giving us a lot more exciting fights
with each arc but today i want to bring
your attention to the whole sequence of
whitebeard pirates vs roger pirates in
universe it's a long fight that lasted
for days
with the members of the crew giving no
edge to the others while displaying
their amazing powers
the two powerful pirate crews go toe to
toe giving us a plethora of highlights
one that includes rayleigh stopping
marco with one finger the sequences and
how the island survives the days of
fighting make this quite the
mind-blowing fight when you think about
it and it's this kind of insanity
that makes one piece such an eye-catcher
quite the epic moment that ends up
turning into a gift exchange event out
of all things
yet it didn't seem like they're out for
blood with how much banter and friendly
the fight seemed but it's the complete
opposite when you think about it
seriously though what is a seven deadly
sin season without some showcase of how
awesome
esquinor is there are reasons why he's
become a fan favorite and a lot of
that's to do with just how overpowered
he is and how he makes a spectacle out
of every fight perhaps as a way to make
up for the hilarious for all the wrong
reasons melioda's fight
we got a far better battle this season
around what more can i say besides
letting you watch the spectacle unfold
i already thought that the fight against
esterosa is great but this one probably
outdid it by a lot it also helps that
zeldris and esquina seem to be more
evenly matched there was more of an
actual fight in this one before zeldras
just falls to an opponent that he in
reality
can't overcome with this fight we just
added another big moment to eskenor's
ever-growing resume
of him being badass and eye-poppingly
awesome
next up we have a fight from season two
of slime rimeru
vs hinata
we've always known rimaru to be one
broken character so first impressions
would make anyone assume that he'll be
the kind to just power through
everything you'd think that it'd be hard
to get a nice
entertaining fight out of him but as
eskenor proved earlier
such a thing is possible case in point
the battle against hinata that starts in
episode six where the fight starts off
fast and furious and rimaru finds
himself being overwhelmed by hinata
speed and technique
even rimeru's counter attacks seem
futile as it seems that the opponent is
always one step ahead of him overall i
like this fight because it gave us a
little bit of everything a display of
powers
check some nice management when it comes
to having this fight spread throughout
multiple episodes
check an overpowered protagonist like
rimaru showing some weakness and having
to resort to trickery
instead of just powering through
challenges check one of the better slime
fights overall the great animation is
just the icing on top
[Music]
foreign
here's an anime that i don't talk about
often world trigger has generally gone
under the radar but once in a while it
does provide us with some cool
fights it's a two-on-four battle as we
have a battle for the expedition ship
it's not easy to produce a fight with so
many people at once while giving them
ample time to shine but that's exactly
what world trigger excels at in a fight
they can easily devolve into an
incoherent mess we have a very fluid and
very engaging four-on-two battle that
takes on numerous turns
this is a great payoff fight that helps
show what makes world trigger good
the fights while remaining quite the
spectacle aren't exactly resolved by
some grand power up like most shonen
instead fight someone through experience
and teamwork now if this fight gets you
going
why don't you check out world trigger
i'd say it's pretty underrated for what
it brings to the table
now if you can't get enough of sci-fi
action how about checking out what
today's sponsors
figurama collectors have for you
introducing the all-new elite solo
statue for kylie of the kick-ass manga
blame
it's the first licensed resin statue for
the hit cyberpunk series of the late 90s
and it's also the grand debut of
figarama's elite solo line a new product
line focused on featuring some
characters
the resin statue also comes with the
greatest seal of authenticity of them
all
a digital signature and stamp of
approval from manga creator sutomo nihi
himself
this item is a sight to behold a thing
of beauty
and it comes with no shortage of
features kili himself has a swappable
animated manga head
so you can relive some of the key
moments of the blame manga and net
animation
it also comes with a bass that comes
equipped with led effects
making this a very intricate and
marvelous addition to your figure
collection and if you're interested
i've got some good news for you the
statue comes with a payment plan for up
to 10 months
so you can take your time and pay as low
as 52 dollars per month on this beauty
but wait
it gets better i also have a promo code
in my description box
so don't forget to start clicking and
get even more discounts on the product
the pre-order starts on march the 27th
at 11
pm jst or 7am pst
so make sure you buy it before they sell
out the links in the description
now back to the show
what i like about the final stretch of
re-zero second season is that there are
multiple climaxes happening concurrently
you have amelia's trial subaru dealing
with evacuating people from the mansion
the battle in the mansion
and the two-on-one battle against
roswell among those climaxes
probably the best fight amongst them is
garfield vs elsa it's brutal of a true
fight as you get this season
most of the violence has been in the
form of one-sided destruction but
garfield's battle with elsa gives us a
good back and forth with probably two of
the toughest non-magical fighters the
series has had so far
it also gives us some good development
for elsa and a lot of nice moments
between the two b-skin siblings as the
battle rages on this is the most
action-packed segment of the whole final
sequence and i loved every single bit of
[Music]
it
[Music]
[Music]
to say that attack on titan's final
season had taken the anime world by
storm is a gross
gross understatement it's such a
juggernaut right now in terms of hype
and reception but i think that it
surpassed season one's fanfare when the
anime series started around a decade ago
and a lot has happened since then but if
one thing remained consistent with
attack on titan besides the really
profound and meaningful narrative and
the extremely well written characters
it's the way all the fights
have an epic feel to them the anime also
shakes things up quite often with the
show
like this battle pretty notable in this
fight is how aaron starts off by not
even letting the warhammer titan
transform he goes right after his
opponent and that's got to be one of the
few times a transformation sequence gets
interrupted in anime hey
he's called the attack titan not the
observer titan nonetheless the two of
them continue to have a slugfest before
the warhammer finally gets the upper
hand but the end of the skirmish
is just the beginning and you'll have to
watch the season to find out what
happens next
next up on the list is astor and yami
versus dante it's been a long
journey but the black clover anime is
about to come to an end that means that
the anime has all the reasons to pull
out all the stops in the final push and
that also means all the more reason to
have more yami being badass
and we just had a dose of that in a
recent episode technically speaking the
fight is astor and yami versus dante but
we mostly just see aster's futile
struggles while dante eventually beats
him black and blue then comes yami and
the real main event begins with the
seemingly unstoppable dante finally
meeting his match
it's quite the drawn out fight that
lasts for a while but if this would be
yami's last hurrah this is an exciting
way to go out
he does win the fight but with the anime
ending soon i think it's about time to
give the young ones their shine
right after their captain puts up one of
the best performances among the many
highlights the show's given us
[Music]
next on the list is kawaki versus garo
let me get one thing straight when it
comes to hand to hand combat the naruto
series never fails you can count on
whatever studio handling naruto to put
out an amazing performance whenever
taijutsu is involved i'm glad that the
tradition continues all the way to
boruto and what could have been seen as
a minor fight we get to see gawaki
fighting garo in what was a surprisingly
amazing fight in terms of animation with
the type of presentation and music you
can just feel the impact of each blow i
can't help but get caught up in the
frenzy and the tempo of the battle
i'm sure that i'm not the only one who
felt this way this isn't even a major
fight
if only boruto can keep up this level of
quality consistently it could have been
a show that more people would flock to
and enjoy
finding its way to the top is the jiu
jitsu sorcerer's fight against hanami
jiu jitsu kaizen had another banger of a
battle recently this time featuring
everyone's favorite mentor and reverse
kakashi once more as well as yuji
and todo in a similar vein to the black
clover fight a while ago this is a
battle that starts off with yuji and
todo trying to hold the line it's not
like they're passive about it or
anything but after overpowering maki and
megumi it's pretty obvious that hanami
is an enemy out of their league still
there's a pretty good fight between the
sorcerers and hanami before big backup
arrives and we have gojo being awesome
again this time it's his hollow purple
nearly destroying hanami outright before
the latter escapes epic animation by
none other than mapa and some great work
by the voice actors elevate this fight
more than what i read in the manga great
anime fights elevate a manga fight more
than its original form
and this is a good example of that
happening
[Music]
that's quite a list now isn't it were
your predictions correct
is there a deserving fight that i failed
to include tell me in the comments
section and i might be able to feature
it on another list
special thanks to zodiac 15 and all
other patreons for making this video
possible don't forget to check out our
sponsors
figurama collector's new elite solo
statue for killi
of the kick ass manga blame links in the
description that'll be it for now
i hope to see you next time and i hope
that you guys stay strong and stay cool
keep tuned for more anime goodness
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you